foreign
[Music]
with its bright orange wings and
intricate black and white details the
monarch butterfly is one of the most
recognizable insects on the planet after
years of declining populations it was
recently declared endangered but the
Beloved Monarch has an army of activists
dedicated to ensuring its survival
Deborah al-farone introduces us to the
next generation of First Responders
answering the call
[Music]
in a garden
at St Joan of Arc School in Aberdeen
Maryland we are looking for weeds to
pull out and caterpillar eggs and we
just found one
all 200 students from pre-k through 8th
grade they're milkweed there's also
lavender are working to keep the
migratory monarch butterfly population
alive I think it's really intriguing
because it really shows how life can
start really small and then it can turn
into something really huge which is what
happens to these butterflies
this Garden is one of about 3 000
certified Monarch way stations at
schools across the country that means it
grows nectar plants and the
all-important milkweed plant the monarch
caterpillar needs to live the baby
caterpillars will eat the milkweed and
then they grow into caterpillars and
make their chrysalises about two weeks
later the metamorphosis is complete and
a breathtaking monarch butterfly can
emerge Eva can tell you why their
survival is so important they are
pollinators so they help the
reproduction of flowers and they help
the ecosystems because they help like
level out the playing field for
different animals for what they need to
do but the garden and the many lessons
it grows wouldn't be here if it weren't
for two forces of nature she always
pushed you to be your best one is former
principal Tracy takarski she strived for
her students to be better than they even
thought they could be jakarski created
the garden the stem and butterfly
Enthusiast died unexpectedly at age 52
right before school started last year do
you feel her presence oh absolutely
Tracy's husband William helped her build
the garden uh
I
I tell you it breaks my heart she had so
much more she would have accomplished
people like her only come once in a
lifetime her love of the tiny insects
can be seen everywhere what's so special
about the monarch butterfly it's about
Charisma Chip Taylor is the second force
of nature if there is a danger and it's
in the future and it's pretty serious
the insect ecologist founded Monarch
watch at the University of Kansas 30
years ago it's the program that inspires
schools like Saint Joan of Arc to plant
milkweed Rich Gardens and organizes the
tagging of these Exquisite creatures to
gather data on their yearly migration
South we really started this as a
research Enterprise and then quickly
learned that we had to morph into
Outreach and become an educational
organization and then in 2004 when it
became clear that we were losing a lot
of habitat to changes in agriculture we
had amorph again into a conservation
organization
Taylor says you can blame a lot of the
loss of monarchs on the widespread use
of herbicides if we're losing monarch
butterflies we're losing other species
that's a little part of a story today
because and potentially losing lessons
this Garden can teach says new principal
Diane Kessler we use it so often to
teach the children so many things caring
for the Earth the life cycle
even our faith of finding your
destination the next step for these
butterflies their yearly migration to
Mexico these are teeny tiny stickers
because their butterfly wings are so
small teachers show the students how
they tag the butterflies so Monarch
watch can collect data about their
Incredible Journey oh and look at that
she was ready to fly
now to the metamorphosis of this
conservation effort after 30 years 2
million butterflies tagged one million
milkweeds planted and 40 000 Gardens
certified it's time for chip to spread
his wings why is it time to retire now
you're not 85 years old yet it's
bittersweet giving up this program to
somebody else because I know it's going
to change I mean it's not going to be
the same thing I created hopefully it'll
be something better
leaving the fight to save Nature's icon
of conservation to the Next Generation
oh
for the Monarch it's about 3 000 miles
for the students of Saint Joan of Arc
and the ones who come after them it's
immeasurable
for CBS Saturday morning Deborah
alfarone Aberdeen Maryland